now Mike what do I have going on today
oh yeah the gun guys I'm talking to the
gun guys about the Second Amendment
that's why I got the gamma fever yes sir
today we're actually meeting with
youngsters who are gun control group
you're gonna have a listening - next
week April 2nd that's today is April 2nd
there's only 1 April 2nd per week I
think per year actually maybe we'll just
cancel the teens no way Mike we can do
them both and that's not the first time
I said that about two years I mean James
James James how many of you are paid
crisis actors or just students twerk
fleek emoji and I think I've reached you
know I want to know what do you think
will make the schools safer and I'm
listening well the first thing we need
to do is meet bands on Knox ok wait
military rifles I'd appreciate if you
take out military great rifles out of
civilian life I would really recommend
rejecting the concealed carry
reciprocity Act which is really
terrifying those that it's so that
people with concealed carry licenses in
any state can have that transferable to
any state I will if you want me to oh
great that make you happy if you didn't
if you did this and then all of you are
gonna take me to your school dance it's
really weird I mean they're probably
gonna stop happening unless you're
something that prevents students from
being in danger danger guns gun people
oh I gotta go to the toilet
give me the card for the gang leader
president
nice to meet you you know listen we got
a band the ar-15 I heard they're like
bad so let's get to work
never gonna happen that can happen
second amendments there for a reason no
one's taking my guns enough of your
propaganda why as a woman do you want a
gun why should I allow someone who wants
to perform an illegal act caused me harm
it's my equalizer I am entitled to use
it so you're saying that guns make us
safer yes it does but the teen said I
mean people are carrying in the
concealing but isn't that dangerous to
be like I'm walking around nobody knows
I have a gun is your driver's license
good in all 50 states
I don't know then your carry permit
should be good in all 50 states and then
everyone would be safe safer problem
solved yeah you know maybe those teens
were wrong Oh
teens I gotta take a shower I'll be
right back
just stay here I gotta look like I
really had a big one go ahead okay hi
I'm back from the toilet
oops while I was sitting on the
porcelain throne I had some time to
think your driver's license works in
every state why can't your gun permit
driving and carrying a gun are really
different things and difficult to do and
difficult like whoa whoa damn it's very
hard to have a conversation with you
we're having a great conversation with
each other we're all talking and
listening developing a sense of boundary
lessness where where do I end and where
do you guys begin major dad there's
still a chance to go to the dance right
no we're gonna have so much fun before
that we go to a house and meet your
parents a dogs good guys I gotta go eat
a snack I told the gun people I gotta
take a shower what are you gonna do oh
boy wow wow wow what a shower I'm all
cleaned up but we need to clean up this
issue the little teen birdie told me
they're scared of guns so how do they
not be afraid of you there should be
fear well you're not afraid of your
father oh you kidding me
most of my memories of my father or me
just looking really close a little only
I'm on the kitchen floor while he's
screaming at me but those were better
days I gotta go wait no we need to have
guns in schools that's just the deal I'm
sorry no now where do you want the limo
to pick each of you up for our date you
haven't done anything and your clothing
you gotta be kidding me you don't want
to go with me I'll show you are cool I
am at the dance my it's been my fidget
all right let's go go
what no sir yeah Oh what you're the gun
people this is your thought you clean up
the no it's not my fault please come
with me young people come out to the
hallway please
oh great the president double-booked
this time yes you did fine the truth is
I can't make a decision I want to be all
things to you and all things to you but
I can't be so I guess I'll be seeing you
at the dance so there's a dance you're
anti-gun not anti guns were pro-gun
control I'm in from having a national
background check with mental health and
crying like I completely agree with
everything you said about background
checks you're both in sort of middle
ground and we both assumed that we were
on yeah exactly
like everybody says all it takes is me
exiting a room to make things better
[Music]